my t-shirt on where's your shirt it's in
the car I'm sorry so failed I did while
we're on that subject I want to give a
shout out to our full screen
representative pair I pare-pare I
appreciate going to the theaters at ipic
watching Luigi origin of evil for free
where we got a pizza popcorn and a free
alcohol beverage yeah and of course a
free screening of Weegee origin of evil
which we're about to review oh and these
make you pay rashly now if you have to
go and then the flashlights ooh and you
have to give a criticism I've been told
you have to say at least three positive
things before you give the criticism
that's a lot of people you guys
represent a full screen over there Oh No
who don't like to shut up during a movie
yeah well was it kind of a talkative
audience a little bit I am so happy
living room EMS other content creators
for also partner with full screen
qui fuh we dream 40 so we saw the movie
Ouija origin of evil this movie is a
sequel to the awesome 2014 film that
everyone really adored for sure there's
a lot of great things in it for starters
I think I feel like when you talk about
great horror films usually end up saying
the same stuff but usually agree shots
and other stuff but but yeah I mean
there's some really cool shots in this
movie them yeah there's some great
framing some great mixture mixing with
like with the focus and the shots
there's plenty of shots in there
especially like the first half of the
film where they do that kind of thing
that like James Wan's sort of known to
do or there's like oh the monsters in
the background but it's so subtle that
the audience has to pay attention to
catch it and like there was one specific
moment that I saw the monster and then
John was like what's going on with
whatever he's one of those it was so
subtle I must have missed it yeah yeah
because all you see are the eyes then
once you capture the eyes and you see
the shape of the body it's really clever
because it's very much in the in the out
of it's like kind of out of focus but
it's it's just like yeah there's some
cool camera techniques in this film
there's a lot of like a mosh style two
films that took place back then they
shot it like a late sixties movie a
league in sacks what diopter shots and
those like slow pans and zooms it did
bother to to make it feel retro in the
styling as well as the art direction it
has kind of that restrained style to me
where it's like it's not going crazy
it's not quite as bonkers as James Bond
film can get but it's still you know
it's still having fun with itself you
know it's so enjoying being a period
piece and a lot of people really
creating the acting on this woman i
think the acting is fantastic in this
movie you got four main characters in
here I'm not good with remembering name
so I'm just reading from IMDb directly
here they had a priest of their father
Tom Tom father taught me she's just been
called John Humphrey cuz it's John's of
priests and so he would have been in
this particular movie or just in general
the general just imagine that's the kind
of pre student nasty it's a really cool
guy I wouldn't still want to sleep with
but now man you're committed as
priesthood and the family they had I
would like the approach they said with
the family because if you guys have seen
the trailer it's reveal them there which
kind of sucks that they do that but
oh that's a very long because the thing
that sucks with the trailer is that when
you see the opening of the film the
opening of the film will be way more
effective and while it still is an
enjoyable opening you can't help but be
like well I saw the trailer so I know
what's really going on that they're con
artists and if you haven't seen the
cheetah 4000 actually didn't remember
the trailer very well I figured it was
coming kind of but I didn't I wasn't
yeah I was like then maybe not yeah but
it was a cool nice touch I'm like
because normally when you see a horror
film and then father has recently passed
in the family usually they're just a
varied our family or probably moving to
some place I was trying to start fresh
but this is just them they're broke and
they're trying to survive yeah keep
their house alive and stuff in the
family you have Annalise Basso then you
have Elizabeth Reaser I'd because for me
playing Alexander the mom of the family
the lead of the con artists family this
is really like matchstick men you know
she's a she she's a psych she has a
business yes psychic mediums it's not
like they're like run around a carnival
Orson like that this is their life now
does Ali make a living you know offer
being a mystic I'm so used to seeing her
on madman and I was kind of excited too
she was only in a few episodes madman
yeah it's true but they were the ones I
saw the most recently no I think she
does a terrific job let's finish
listening off the caster Annalise Basso
is paulina Xander she was really good
too what I appreciate more in more in
horror movies is maybe when they
introduce a character who's like not
such an original character but they make
them better and more developed since the
real / they make the art type of that
character work you know rebellious teen
daughter they made it in sent in such a
better depth or it didn't feel like
you're watching something typically you
still feel like you're watching a
different kind of teenage daughter yeah
I mean it doesn't forget to flesh out
its characters and it doesn't forget
that their lives are important yes story
it's not tied in and that sort of like
oh it was destined to be this way so
yeah but it's like this really does
affect their lives and who they are as
people and like that it's nice that they
still pay attention to that all the way
through you know yeah and then the final
one is the little girl the main little
girl ya can't trust little girls in
horror films Lulu Wilson green doors I
feel like child actors they get their
best breaks with her [ __ ] horror
films little girls and horror movies
they either do
like an awful job or they they do like a
really good job like something super
effective yeah this little girl was
really good the time when I really
admired her the little girl has this
speech at one point where she's
describing a strangling and what happens
to someone when they start to die from
being choked to death her delivery on it
was really [ __ ] awesome I was really
impressed with how she did it cuz she
wasn't just I'm a creepy little girl
mm-hmm like the typical cliche thing
there was something there's there's an
extra layer her that although her
character was possessed something about
her seemed to also kind of like it like
there it was it was an interesting mix
that you couldn't at that moment I
couldn't really tell is this the demon
talking or is this just her and part of
her to life's to communicate with the
thing that's possessed in her you know
or what is the mixture of the two
exactly yeah so that I like him like she
is actually a medium yeah for real and
even like the boyfriend cliche character
of the daughter with the boyfriend there
was something about the roll round like
you know what I like together yeah
charming guy yeah it takes a lot of
these tropes that were used to but it
plays them really really well and it
gives you an interesting version of all
of them yeah that is fresh that feels
like an authentic choice yeah so it's
like it it doesn't rien it's that old
saying I was like it doesn't reinvent
the wheel but it takes all these tropes
and makes them more interesting gives
them their own sort of unique character
feeling like it does take time for for
its characters to really be involved ok
so we established plenty of good things
criticisms now one way to look at it is
to just go this isn't one of those films
that doesn't reinvent the wheel but it
does is execution very well on what it's
working with yes absolutely at the same
time though that is part of my complaint
with it was that I felt that this easily
could have been something that adds
something fresh add something new and
for me I really felt like although
there's effective moments and the
writing of the characters is good
there's a lot of great things in this
woman I'd say overall it's a pretty good
movie I think is a good studio [ __ ]
yeah everything in there just seemed
like this is taken from this horror
movie
just taken from this horror movie this
is taken from this horror movie that's
the double-edged sword of doing
something like that it's like I don't
feel it as much as you do but I do agree
it's like there were a number of times
where i was even watching and going ok I
can I can feel inspiration for arm
reminded of this now or I'm reminded of
it yeah movie I was reminded a little
bit of like American Horror Story at
certain points total in that lately one
of my feelings was I feel like it could
have gone a little bit more and I wasn't
sure exactly what I wanted from it
that's what I love about a horror film
was I'm not entirely sure what I want
all I know is that they just got to
deliver something they'll provide me
with a feeling yeah by the time movie
was done I felt like I was watching a
movie that was building up for something
much bigger throughout the whole thing
with what they gave us even the reveal
of like who's the who are the ghosts
that are me that are doing the
possessions in the haunting like I was
like I've heard that explanation of a
ghost before it's like they took art
types that I've seen in other horror
movies before and they just did a really
good job with what that was given to
them sometimes there's a overuse of some
CGI in there that did kind of pull me
out at certain points and I'm conflicted
because like I like the idea but there
are times where the modernist almost
gets in the way of everything else being
a pretty nice period yeah so like when
there is an abundance of CGI like face
warping at least I was a little kind of
pulled out and there are some things
like especially like the last 15-20
minutes of the film where my time it was
over I just had like these questions I'm
like well this doesn't add up like like
I can't give it away because it was be a
toll spoiler there are things that
happen wrong especially the last shot of
the movie the last shot of the movie
just left me with so many questions
mm-hmm based off of like what had just
happened a few minutes ago if you guys
watching you might figure out what i'm
talking about it i felt he could have
just got a little bit crazy with its
story it not in terms of just visual
scares or whatever I don't know there
was something there that was just
missing for me and I can't quite put my
finger on her right now it felt a little
bit like there was like an act missing
yet if it looked up just the right
amount of time the movie you know it's
weird it might be because I'm like so
into American Horror Story right now and
I've been binge-watching seasons I'm
kind of used to like watching horror
things that are inspired by other horror
things but they they go [ __ ] balls
out by the end you know
but this movies bread and butter isn't
being balls out the movie they tried to
make is a more restrained kind of you
know slightly elegant horror movie it
feels like a ghost story it's short you
know it's it's a ghost story and yeah
that's that's also fair though I'm sure
whether or not you're okay with that
decides which version of that you say I
don't know I mean normally when we share
reviews we usually just don't come back
right after and talk about them yeah
usually like give ourselves like a day
toes or them so we can really know how
we actually talked like people became
the movie i will say everything that you
that you really do go to a horrible
before you're pretty much gonna get
there's a lack of true originality for
me in this film with that being said
though i still think that there's a lot
of very effective things they do and
they toy with things that might not seem
original at first but then they like the
way they mess with it or the way they
have fun with its tools makes it
somewhat original to me it had a sort of
genuine quality in the way it played out
in the way in sort of sculpted itself
you don't want to look at everything and
go well for what it is it did it really
well I think this movie won me a lot of
times by not only doing well but like
excelling like not only is it an
effective like an effectively put
together ghost story it's also got great
performances that I was actually
impressed by I was actually really
invested in and they really paid
attention to the story I mean there are
questions that i do have towards the end
that we're a little unclear to me but
they really seem like they put a lot of
effort into the story into having you
know any interesting little family it's
three female leads you know it's like
it's a different kind of it's not the
usual like father mother and young son
or used to seeing like it's they took
some time to make some things distinct
and different it's really well put
together on top of all that there were
times when i noticed the editing was
really interesting or they were choosing
interesting shots some great sound
effects to some great sound effect it's
like it's there are things I think are
legit great in so many different parts
of this that I liked it a lot still it
doesn't reinvent the wheel and that's
for yeah yeah it's pretty good yeah i
mean like i think john and i should use
re rating system you sure yeah that's
it's the rating system yeah this is the
defined ratings good fair poor yeah your
options have options
John please let's not insult the rating
system okay fine decent is three options
yeah because they don't mean the same
thing you know but maybe fantastic or
amazing or great I'll mean the same
thing somebody where's the line man well
we can combine fantastic amazing and
great it's for good yeah what the
grounded ratio your snail has changed
John I'm just checking with a very
original I feel like people are just
trying to get too clever with their
words these days what the [ __ ] is a
b-minus mean how funny come on her seven
what I her feed my was like what this is
a bird would maybe good time if you're
drunk what's it racist anticipate what's
a Schmo what is three out of five
schmoes me look so is pretty good lately
gosh it's really good yeah we should
have like a category of you know like
above good which would be like really
good it's pretty good uh yes it's all
good great you put options on your
options but you can put options John
there's a lot of whale room with the
reason uh yeah if you need the channel
you can subscribe today become a read
yeah John yeah uh this movie was
produced by bloom house it was that's
why John was in full support and
everything about centers so John's 100
bias during this whole review
facebook.com slash bloom house he's all
on top of that [ __ ] all day long he's
just on facebook all day and then he's
on facebook all day on the real rejects
as well and he's reasons is Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram I'm the greg alba
on twitter and instagram i want you to
know kids that if you're watching this
video it's okay you're not doing
anything illegal
that's a suspicious thing to say